in the immediate there
is no better time than now to talk a
little bit about
uh the plans for people who are voting
in very blue states and in very red
states who maybe you're planning to vote
third party
maybe you're planning not to vote at all
because the outcome in your state is
essentially determined now as
most of you probably know in the united
states we don't have a national popular
vote we have an electoral college so
if you win a state as a presidential
candidate by just
one vote you get all of that state's
electoral
votes and it has no impact on what
happens in other states it's really 50
individual elections
because of that system that we have
really
the election is determined by a dozen or
so battleground states or swing states
as they're sometimes called so
these include places like wisconsin
north carolina ohio florida
etc and it's very common that people in
very blue or very red states who are on
the left will say to me i get these
phone calls i hear from people in person
etc they'll say you know i live in utah
biden's not going to win
i might vote third party or i might not
vote or whatever
and then i'll hear from people in states
like my state of massachusetts who say
biden is winning by what is it at this
point 30 40. it's crazy what biden's
winning by in massachusetts
it doesn't really require my vote to
make sure biden gets
massachusetts electoral vote so i i
might vote
maybe i'll vote green party to give them
some support or whatever
if there was ever an election where that
is not the approach that we should have
it is this one if there was ever an
election where
every blue state and red state voter
needs to make sure that you are voting
for joe biden it is this one and you
probably can
guess why i'm going to make this point
there is a very real possibility
that donald trump will claim that the
election wasn't fair
that it was rigged that the results are
wrong
and in particular if it's very close
nationally or within the key states that
end up being the determining factors
we may have a situation where not only
do we not know the results on november
3rd i mean with the number of mail-in
ballots we're going to have it's
certainly reasonable and not a problem
for me
that maybe we don't know the results
until november sixth or seventh
seventh i want the right results rather
than the fast results but put that aside
for a second
we could again end up with a situation
where the supreme court gets involved
here
and some people sent me a clip of sam
cedar recently talking about this saying
we might not know who won on tuesday and
trump will in all likelihood claim that
he won
lawsuits may start in a variety of
different states
and it could be a never-ending battle so
we need a large
margin in every single state
and also we want the largest possible
popular vote margin why well because if
it does get to either
secretaries of state or supreme court
justices the more overwhelming the
defeat is
of donald trump if we are going to get
one the more difficult it's going to be
for supreme court justices to justify
funny business we'll leave it at that
which could end up handing the election
to donald trump there's no guarantee
um as we know the supreme court is
liable to do anything at any time
but the point is winning the popular
vote by 3 million votes which is roughly
what hillary clinton did in 2016
while still seeing donald trump become
president with an electoral college
victory
that's just going to be too close and if
this extends a few days
into weeks because of lawsuits and on
and on into the supreme court
particularly while donald trump is
trying to kneecap the postal service
to try to prevent vote-by-mail absentee
ballots from being delivered we need to
do everything we can
to avoid small margins anywhere we want
to avoid small margins
in the states that will be close we want
to avoid small margins or smaller
margins than we could have in california
and massachusetts we need to run the
score up and if the election comes down
to a couple of states
and the popular vote is closer rather
than less close
it just better enables donald trump to
claim whatever the hell
he plans to claim if we overwhelm the
vote so much
that trump is crushed in the popular
vote the claims are just
slightly harder to make seriously
california has millions and millions of
democrats and joe biden's clearly going
to win who cares
go out and vote and run up the score in
california massachusetts will easily go
to joe biden
you'd better believe i'm going to be
voting and encouraging everybody i know
who votes in massachusetts to be voting
everybody has to vote because we have to
i don't know of a better term than to
run
up the score and then and only then
if we succeed in removing donald trump
then we go back to what i discussed
earlier which is we will have to deal
with trumpism
and the 60 62 64 66 million
people who will have seen the last three
and a half years and will say yeah give
me another
four years of that following sam cedar's
logic on this which i think is sound
um it's possible that overwhelming
margins
could sway one supreme court justice you
don't have to
if it's going to be 5-4 in some decision
over some lawsuit that trump files
if it's going to be 5-4 an overwhelming
popular vote
victory swinging one of those nine votes
could make all the difference in who
ends up being president as of january
20th
2021 uh and voting is something we can
all do
it's our right let's exercise it august
23rd
is the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show we will have a huge
membership special i can't say any more
about it because it's borderline
illegal certainly immoral but maybe even
illegal in some states
be notified of this great membership
special by grabbing a membership
i'm sorry by getting on our newsletter
at davidpakman.com
you will then on august 23rd be notified
of how to take advantage of this great
membership discount